can I tell them our disagreement yes I
thought you'd be interested because
there's a base important you'd have it
may be interesting very so so I
personally don't think that pluralism
religious pluralism religiously plural
is positioned which says all faiths are
equally true and equally valid ways of
accessing the divine I don't think it's
intellectually coherent I think it's
muddled so that's that's one thing and
we can discuss that now i'm prepared to
when you say intellectually mother i I
mean as opposed to just not something
you agree with as it were well no here
focus well I disagree believe that all I
mean it's not as a matter of fact what I
believe but obviously you could believe
that all face you could believe that but
I don't think I don't think it's it's a
coherent a coherent position therefore I
think it's a wrong position yeah I
concluded i could put it strongly like
and partly i believe because the
religious traditions make truth claims
and those truth claims are not
compatible often and so the second thing
I I think something like a soft
exclusivism is actually the most
compelling position to I don't think
that non-exclusive ism of faiths is the
most important aspect in their
contribution to two piece I think that
commitment to respect the dignity
fundamental dignity of each person and
commitment to care for another person
whether your faith is exclusive or
non-exclusive is more important for the
peace processes then whether you think
that that person's belief system is true
ah
or or not right but I would like I would
agree with that but i would say i would
say that but aren't you more likely the
less less vehement your exclusivity or
what you know what i mean the more
vehement your view that your religion is
exclusive is that not more likely to
mean that you you you don't regard those
things important right that there are
kinds of exclusive isms like in Northern
Ireland Protestants of Northern Ireland
they're very good example it was
exclusivism which said basically i think
in simple terms God loves only us God
doesn't love the nasty Catholics right
there papist and so forth they're out of
the purview of God's law i remember i
was there when i was talking about
Christ universal love for instance and
their hands at pop I went up in the air
and they said no that's not true God's
love is limited to certain crowd of
folks and it doesn't apply to the
Catholic now if you have that view
exclusive is view I think that that's
really pernicious and completely
unacceptable and it undermines
reconciliation process totally and
foster smile but if you have exclusive
is faith which says I ought to love
every person because God loves every
person I ought to respect every person
because everyone is made in the image of
God then exclusivity will not be in
conflict with peace process never not
wish I would agree with that it's just
that I think that that sorely coming
here to third and I can i yeah there we
go that's good yeah the question of
pluralism is coherent yeah my own view
is that the truth claims are all
untestable by mortal man from one and
that having accepting that fact is for
me to basis
pluralism which says they are all
credible and indistinguishable at an elf
epistemological level as as faiths as
ways of relating to God yeah I
conclusion would be there not strictly
testable because fates are different
things than kind of empirical faith
statements are different kinds of
statements and empirical statements but
i wouldn't say for that reason that i
cannot affirm them as truth claims and
therefore have to say there are 15 truth
claims that are different and all are
equally true because i can test that one
of them what instead i say because of
this limited ability to test is that i
need to fold and have to fold religious
convictions with a certain provision
allottee with a certain sense of the
mystery beyond which simply says my
thing that i think is true is such that
i cannot assert my knowledge as absolute
about something that is inherently
beyond the capacity of human beings flew
to grasp